i guess if you could quickly outline our
current meeting crisis because we talked
about how it builds up to this
our current meeting crisis and then
where do you think it's going to go
a little bit of prediction is it are you
optimistic
what's what do we need to heal it i know
that's a big
i know that's another two hour
conversation yeah because that's what
the whole series is
about uh so one of the things that's
really important now
that's accelerating the meeting crisis
you notice how we've talked about
along the way things have happened that
and they accelerate the meaning crisis
and they're often in
psychotechnologies and and now we have
this line and you mentioned it earlier
that's blurring
between psychotechnologies and cyber
technologies you know
this social media the internet
right these things are and and we're
getting increasing evidence
are significantly accelerating and
exacerbating the meaning crisis
right this instagram is actually bad for
your mental health
you're spending a lot of time on
instagram i predict as a scientist
you're you're you're going to be you're
going to be very depressed
and you're going to be driven towards a
narcissistic causal yes
yes because you see all these pictures
of these people
living a better life than you and it's
all [ __ ] right because
it's all staged but that doesn't matter
knowing that doesn't matter it's like
the
buying the alcohol right and so you see
this and
you're getting signals that these people
are being better lives than me
and you're getting overwhelmed by it and
then you feel like and and
nobody likes me look at that look at
that that's the place of the god
saying oh i like you right but the
community on it
i'm not getting enough likes and my i
don't have my pic
my life oh no and you're just depressed
and you're both
narcissistic and depressed it's very bad
for you
right or you get the you get the echo
chamber effect
remember we talked about self-delusion
and the way you can [ __ ] yourself
social media echo i i can i can do
confirmation bias all over the place
i can right i i want to believe some
crazy thing
and so what do i do i'll pay attention
i'll only look on the internet for
people who share my beliefs
and then i'll reinforce that and until
oh of course it must be true
all of this stuff is exacerbating people
and we get a tremendous increase in
sense of
of loneliness right the the very thing
you know it promises
it'll connect us all together it
connects us propositionally and with
images
a kind of pornography of salience but it
doesn't connect us in the way
that makes meaning for us and so i think
the
the the i mean there is tremendous
potential
right i'm not a luddite i mean i'm using
the internet i'm using youtube right and
and then
so that's i'm ultimately optimistic uh
precisely because the the people i'm
meeting through the
the video series and and some of the the
the discourse that i'm seeing
emerging like in the internet right
i'm meeting people who are deeply
interested in the meeting crisis and not
just
in in speech there's they're trying to
set up communities
where you know where people can go to
reestablish
you know you know sets of practices
supportive communities guides for the
cultivation of wisdom
the the affordance of self-transcendence
people doing this
trying to set these up make this work
trying to figure out
how can we develop skills and practices
to
reduce the [ __ ] in our communication
how can we
bring back the valuation of in-person
discourse and dialogue like all of this
is happening and one of the great gifts
of the video series is i've come more
and more in contact
through the internet with these people
and i'm doing
i meet you because of it right the same
thing and and so
on one hand i think we can see it's
clear
i think that you know the social media
and all these cyber psycho technologies
are
really accelerating the meaning crisis
in very powerful ways
i'm not ultimately i'm i'm not
teleological i don't think there's any
destined history
but i have a lot of hope now that i
didn't have before precisely because i
see people
like i mean i was talking to a guy this
morning right and he he he owns a dojo
and he's we're dialoguing but how can i
you know do what you know the the
martial arts used to do
how can i teach people the martial arts
in the context of other practices
so that the dojo becomes a place where
they cultivate wisdom and they start to
get these kinds of connections we're
talking about
and they can start to respond to the
meeting crisis in their own lives
like so this this is more and more
happening so
i i i can't make a prediction in the in
in
you know the way you know a scientist
can predict you know the dependent
variable and the independent variable
i predict these two things and it's it's
unclear to me
because there's a race you know the
degree to which
social media and our political
polarization
and the and and the degradation of the
ecology
and and the increasing economic
disparities
right between rich and poor all of these
things are
like interacting with each other all of
that's happening
but i'm also seeing this growth and it's
growing rapidly
right of people taking seriously
not just in words but bringing back to
the words
the transformative processes they're
trying to afford
psychotechnologies and communities of
transformation
to respond to the meeting crisis and
it's unclear to me
who's going to win this race but i have
a lot more hope than i used to